[Music]
welcome back to Harbor unbox today we're
checking out a new gForce GPU and if
there was some kind of quick way that I
could convey to you my feelings on this
one um put there I guess this would be
it gee this is pretty wobbly Balin um I
feel like I'm going to fall off here and
crash harder than video's stock oh death
cold probably probably bit too soon for
those
jokes uh just move that aside uh yeah so
uh yeah we're checking out the GeForce
RTX 4080 TI super been over this so many
times it's a
580 sorry I do of course mean the
GeForce RTX 580 this is NV video's new
$11,000 us offering so it's coming in at
half the price of the
R RTX 5090 yeah not 4092 are 5090 you
got it that time I'm getting better at
this job guys so with this one the 80
compared to the 5090 you're basically
getting half the specs for half the
price there half the cores roughly half
the memory bus half the vrm and almost
half the memory bandwidth today's
sponsor spot is brought to you by
thermal Grizzly and their cryos sheet
graphine thermal pads which are an
excellent alternative to thermal pastes
they offer very high thermal
conductivity with no liquid components
so they can't dry out and therefore
don't degrade over time like pastes and
even liquid Metals Crow sheet is very
easy to use it's extremely durable and
is available in a range of sizes to suit
most applications I've personally done
some high-end GPU testing with Crow
sheet and the results were impressive
very similar in fact to that of liquid
metal but without the mess and of course
no risk of drying out so for more
information please check the link in the
video
description nvidia's created a massive
gap between the 580 and 590 which is no
doubt an attempt to upsell Gamers on the
much faster and much more expensive 5090
plus it leaves them a good amount of
room to release more expensive gForce 50
Super Series cards in 12 months time or
so that correct the obvious vram issues
with much of the Blackwell lineup so
that's fun in terms of specifications
the RTX 580 is only a very minor upgrade
over the RTX 480 super nvidia's previous
generation $1,000 us GPU the RTX 580
includes just 5% more cores which are
clocked a mere 3% higher and the only
real upgrade here is the move to gddr 7
memory which uses the same 256-bit wide
bus but the bandwidth has been increased
by 30% thanks to 30 gbits per second
memory truth to be told though the RTX
480 super probably wasn't that memory
limited anyway so in in reality the
upgrades on offer here are likely going
to result in a very minor performance
Improvement and of course we are about
to look into that but before we do jump
into the blue barographs here's a look
at how nvidia's found his Edition
version of the RTX 580 handles and I'll
compare it to the RTX 480 Fe card for
this testing I'm using the Last of Us
Part One at 4K maxed out and after an
hour of load inside an enclosed ATX case
we saw a peak GPU temperature of 63°
which is remarkable given how quite and
compact this graphics card is the fan
speed peaked at just, 1400 RPM and
couldn't be heard over our case fans
which are already very quiet the core is
clocked at an average frequency of
2,655 MHz with an average GPU power
drawer of 266 wats the memory peaked at
72° with an operating frequency of 2,500
MHz for a transfer speed of 30 gbits per
second now compare that to the Fe model
which saw the GPU Peak at 62° and the
memory at 74° while the fans spun at
just over 1300 RPM so it's clear that
the 580 design is a bit more efficient
at least in terms of size but ignoring
the physical size of these graphics
cards the end result is much the same so
again great stuff here from the new Fe
model but how does it perform in terms
of FPS well let's go find out starting
with Marvel Rivals at 1440p the new RTX
580 was good for 108 FPS which makes it
just 8% faster than the 7 900 XTX and
14% faster than the 480 super it was
also just 9% slower than the 490 so
that's not too bad given it should cost
a lot less but of course let's go check
out the 4K results here the 580 looks a
little more impressive well ever so
slightly more impressive as it's now 16%
faster than the 480 super and 12% faster
than the 7900 XTX so it is faster it's
not much faster in this example but at
least it's faster next up we have
stalker 2 and here the 580 is just 4%
faster than the 480 super at 1440p while
it was also just 3% faster than the
Radeon RX 7900
XTX now jumping up to the 4K resolution
doesn't really change much here the 580
is just 4% faster than the 7900 XTX and
9% faster than the 480 super so pretty
dismal numbers here I would say and the
580 really struggles in Counter Strike
too managing to come in 4% slower than
the 480 super at 1440p and a rather
large 133% slower than the 7900 XTX it
does recover a little bit at 4K beating
the older 4080 super by a mere 5% margin
though it was still slower than the
radon GPU trailing the 7900 XTX by an 8%
margin so I think overall that's pretty
bad the God of War Ragnarok results were
also highly disappointing at 1440p the
580 was just 4% faster than the 480
super and again came in slower than the
7900 XTX though only by a few frames in
this example the 4K data is more
promising as here the 80 managed to pull
ahead of the 7900 XTX by a 9% margin and
then the 480 super by an 8% margin so
still very disappointing results for a
Next Generation product but at least in
this example it was
faster for some reason the new GeForce
50 Series gpus are massively
underwhelming in Delta Force certainly
much more so than other games at 1440p
the 580 was 10% slower than the 480
super and 12% slower than the 7900 XTX
so that's obviously very bad and even at
4K it was still slower than both the 480
super and 7900 XTX and although the
margins here were reduced it's still a
terrible result overall the Space Marine
2 results are better but even so the RTX
580 was just 6% faster than the 4080
super at 1440p and then 18% faster than
the 7900 XTX and then at 4K we're
looking at a 21% increase over the 480
super so certainly one of the better
results we've seen so far and it was
also 27% faster than the 7900
XTX the Star Wars Joo Survivor
performance is also extremely
underwhelming here the 580 was just 2%
faster than the 17900 XTX at 1440p and
5% faster than the 4080 super the 4K
results though are much more favorable
but even so the 580 is still just 15%
faster than the 7900 XTX and 19% faster
than the 480 super I think at 19% we're
starting to get up there though it's
still a pretty mild gain for New
Generation but I think if we were seeing
a minimum of 19% that would be
passible a plague tail requium has more
reasonable gains for us certainly better
than most other titles we've looked at
so far here the RTX 580 was 15% faster
than the 480 super at 1440p and 18%
faster than the 7900
XTX oddly however the RTX 580 was just
11% faster than the 1700 XTX at 4K and
15% faster than the 480 super so pretty
disappointing that the margins didn't
grow relative to what we saw at
1440p even performance in cyberpunk 2077
is pretty underwhelming at 1440p the RTX
580 was a mere 9% faster than the RTX
480 super and 7% faster than the radon
7900 XTX jumping up to 4K helped the 580
a little bit but but even so it was just
10% faster than the 1700 XTX and 16%
faster than the 480 super which
disappointingly are some of the better
margins we have seen for the new GeForce
50 Series
gpus Dying Light 2 saw a 12% increase
for the 580 over the 480 super at 1440p
along with an 11% increase over the 7900
XTX so yeah I think it's fair to say
disappointing results once again and at
4K we're looking at slightly larger
margins but still just 18% faster than
the 7900 XTX and 20% faster than the 480
super which is about the biggest margins
we've seen so far Dragon Age has more
weak gains for us just a 9% uplift over
the 480 super at 1440p and 15% over the
7900 XTX the 4K data isn't much better
just a 16% increase over the 480 super
and 18% over the 7900 XTX it's certainly
not nothing but but it's also very
underwhelming for a Next Generation
product especially after all of this
time the RTX 580 is only able to match
the 4080 super in War Thunder at 1440p
though that did make it much faster than
the 7900 XTX as the radon GPU is
massively underperforming this title
when using the default directx11 mode
performance is much better for the
Radeon gpus using directx12 but for now
that is not the default API for this
title and is labeled as beta or beta if
you're from the US then at 4K the RTX
580 is 3% faster than the 4080 super and
12% faster than the 7900 XTX so again
very similar margins there performance
in a Spider-Man remastered is very
underwhelming and while the data might
be mostly CPU Limited at 1440p that's
certainly not the case at 4K and yet
despite that the 580 is only able to
match the 480 super and 7900
XTX next up we have Hogwarts Legacy and
at 1440p the 580 is just 12% faster than
the 480 super but also 5% slower than
the 7900 xdx that increase in the
resolution to 4K does help the 580 and
now it's 22% faster than both the 7900
XTX and 480 super which might be the
most impressive margin we've seen yet
moving on to the Last of Us Part One
here the 580 was only able to match the
4080 super at 1440p making it 6% slower
than the 7900 XTX
then at 4K it was able to match the 7900
XTX and was there 7% faster than the 480
super so again I know I've said it time
and time again but this is pretty
disappointing and I'm sorry to say but
the Star Wars Outlaws results are just
as disappointing at 1440p the 580 was a
mere 3% faster than the 480 super though
it was 16% faster than the 17900 XTX
because this game does use rage racing
with the ultra quality settings and that
of course hurts the on gpus because
they're not particularly good at rate
tracing then at 4K it was just 5% faster
than the 480 super and 177% faster than
the 7900
XTX finally we have Starfield and at
1440p the 580 was just 2% faster than
the 4080 super while it trailed the 7900
XTX by a 2% margin then at 4K it nudged
ahead of the 7900 XTX by a mere 3%
margin though that did make it 8% faster
than the 480 super so
that's it really mostly singled digigit
gains it seems but let's move on to
check out the average performance scene
across the 17 games that we just looked
at now although I didn't bother going
over the 1080p numbers here's the
average data for those of you interested
basically the 580 was only able to match
the 4080 super here mostly due to CPU
limited results but it does seem as
though the Blackwell architecture
struggles a little more than the
previous generations Outlaw resolutions
and this isn't always the result of a
CPU bottle NE then at 1440p we're
looking at a mere 4% performance
increase for the 580 over the 480 super
just 4% on average or 5% over the 7900
XTX but hey that's better than the 2%
uplift we got from the 480 to the 480
super so maybe things are looking up
after all now at 4K things do look much
better sure the 580 was on average just
11% faster but we have achieved double
digits but yeah also H it's pretty
disappointing pretty horrible for Next
Generation GPU if I'm perfectly honest
it's just a 14% increase over the
original RTX 480 and when compared to
the nearest arrival from AMD it's just
an 8% increase over the 7900 XTX the
good news is power consumption is quite
good at least based on our 1440p testing
as here the 580 consumed anywhere from 4
to 19% less power than the 4080 super
and considerably less than the radon RX
7900 XTX
sadly however the RTX 580 isn't anything
special when it comes to rate tracing
only delivering an 11% increase over the
480 super at 1440p in Metro Exodus
though that did make it almost 50%
faster than the 17900 XTX so as we
always say if you care about RT
performance just get yourself a GeForce
GPU then moving to 4K shows more of the
same the 580 was 14% faster than the 480
super the Metro Exodus results aren't
that unusual Al though Allen wake to at
1440p shows that there is very little
between the 480 super and 580 when it
comes to RT performance there is some
separation at 4K but even here the 80
could only distance itself from the 480
super by a 12% margin so very
underwhelming stuff there the cyberpunk
2077 data is more of the same the 480
super and 580 are comparable at 1440p
and then at 4K using quality upscaling
with the ultra Raad tracing preset we're
looking at just 50 FPS on average for
the 580 and yet it was just 6% faster
than the 480 super Marvel Spider-Man
remastered saw no performance difference
between the 580 and 480 super at either
1440p or 4K both tested using dlss
quality upscaling we're seeing a 9%
uplift In Dying Light to at 1440p for
the 580 over the 480 super which is
surprisingly one of the better RT gains
we've seen so far and that margin isn't
extended ever so slightly to 10% at 4K
but hey at least it's 55% faster than
the 7900 XTX you're looking at just 70
FPS on average in black myth Wukong when
using rid tracing at 1440p with quality
dlss upscaling and that's 11% faster
than the 4080 super the 4K data shows
more of the same really so pretty
terrible gains really and you can't
claim a CPU bottleneck for this
testing okay so again we didn't look at
1080p R tracing data but here it is
using quality upscaling the 580 and 480
super basically delivered identical
performance making the 580 almost 80%
faster than the 7900 XTX then at 1440p
the 580 was just 5% faster than the 480
super while the radio on gpus are
irrelevant here then finally at 4K using
quality upscaling the RTX 580 was just
9% faster than the 4080 super on average
so I guess so much for an improvement in
RT performance then
okay so in a perfect world where GPU
sold at the
MSRP or not so perfect I guess when
we're talking about $11,000 products but
in a world where the MSRP was a thing
for all gpus the RTX 580 doesn't look
terrible that would also certainly
doesn't look like a Next Generation
product offering just 11% better value
than the RTX 480 super and for many
months you could easily purchase the 480
super at the $1,000 MSRP so this isn't
anything new
essentially if you wanted roughly this
level of performance from a 16 GB
GeForce GPU you could have got it a
Euro and proving that point if we look
at the best pricing from mid 2024 and
many of these prices were available for
most of the year if the RTX 580 arrives
for $11,000 us it will be providing a
mere 8% Improvement in terms of value
over a product you could have easily
purchased at least 6 months prior and
not only that but if you don't care
about rate tracing the 7900 XTX is
arguably better value again though I do
think for $100 more if it does indeed
end up being $100 more the RTX 580 is
still a better buy but again given how
competitive older Parts like the 700 XTX
and 480 super R I think the 580 is
extremely
underwhelming so there you have it the
gForce RTX 4080 TI super actually Jokes
Aside it's probably not even that good
in terms of cost per frame the 4080
super was almost 20% better value than
the 480 whereas the 80 looks to be at
best just 10% better value than the 4080
super and on that note I'm sure some
will say that we should be comparing the
RTX 580 with the original 480 but that's
complete nonsense that's because the RTX
480 was essentially a failed product and
I'm not even talking about the
unlaunched ad 104 version the 48 that we
ultimately got for $1,200 us was a joke
and thankfully the majority of you guys
so Gamers agreed and that resulted in
stock just sitting on shelves forcing
Nvidia to release the 480 super and that
was essentially the same GPU in terms of
performance but with $200 us knocked off
the price so a bit of a unofficial price
uh cut there given that it only makes
sense to compare the RTX 580 with the
480 super and once you do you quickly
realize there's very very little on
offer here stuff like multiframe
generation can be useful though it is
extremely situational and for the most
part you're not really missing out on
anything there and where still the truly
exciting DLS S4 features will be coming
to previous generation RTX gpus anyway
so if the RTX 580 ends up coming in a
little over $1,000 us it'll line up more
with the RTX 480 super in terms of value
and at that point it wouldn't matter too
much which one you purchased of course
you might as well get the 80 because
it's newer but other than that there's
real no compelling reason for why you
would buy it and that being the case you
certainly wouldn't pay a premium for it
would you so all of that said I think in
order for the GeForce RTX 580 not to be
a complete disaster and sit on shelves
like the original 4080 did it can't sell
for more than $1,000 us so hopefully the
MSRP is more realistic than how the 5090
is shaping up to be based on all the
leaked pricing that we're seeing as a
side note for those of you with GeForce
30 series gpus who have been holding out
for four years now going on 5 years I
suppose the RTX 580 is 67% faster than
the RTX 380 for a 43% price increase
though I suppose if you adjust for
inflation it's more like a 20% price
increase so if I were to recalculate the
cost per frame adjusting for inflation
the cost per frame of the RTX 580 has
improved by 28% relative to the 380 so
again certainly not an amazing upgrade
after all of this time and you are
without question paying a premium for
the 80 and you could have achieved a
similar upgrade at least 6 months ago
with a 4080 super overall though what
can you say the RTX 5090 was
disappointing in our opinion offering
around 30% more performance on average
it was 27% in our benchmarks but you
know people found between 25 and 30% so
we'll be generous and go 30% and it cost
at least 25% more money based on you
know the MSRP
so if all of that was
disappointing I'm not really sure what
to make of the RTX 580 but I'm confident
once reviews go live we'll have a pretty
good understanding of where the
community is on this one and not just
reviewers obviously what all of you guys
thought about it I don't think it's
going to be too well received but you
know don't want to be overly negative
we'll see what you guys have to say and
we'll continue to form our opinion I
suppose but you've got all the
information all the data now there'll be
many reviews I suggest you check as as
many of them out as you can and then you
can form your opinion once you're armed
with all of that information but yeah
that is going to do it for my review of
the RTX 4080 TI
super um again leave your comments below
I'll be sure to read them like the video
If you enjoyed it subscribe for more
content because we do actually have a
lot of really cool partner card reviews
coming up so well this product may be
underwhelming uh if you're buying a GPU
over the next year two years it may be
of the better value options so it's
worth knowing what the partner cards
have to offer there but I've pretty much
said all the things uh there's the join
button patreon if you want to support
the channel more directly and get
involved in our exclusive live streams
for members only Discord server uh
behind the scenes content Q&A stuff then
check that out but if not that's
perfectly fine and I would like to thank
you for watching this video I'm your
host Steve see you again next time but
seriously if I do fall off here I kind
of hope I end up in a coma it's bit
morbid to say but you know you could
wake me up when Hardware's exciting
again um or one of those what is it
Amnesia they get you know one of those
we could we could make a movie where a
hardware reviewer falls off a stool
doing a bit gets Amnesia by the time he
learns how to re Benchmark again gpus
are
exciting uh anyway I'm going to hop down
before this before you know I I do end
up with amnesia
[Music]